découverts chez ruquier cet ancien
professeur de sciences et vie de la
terre à plus d'une vanne dans son sac et
ses personnages qu'elle campe avec brio
témoigne d'un imaginaire drôle et
forcément décalé outre le grand point
virgule à paris et bientôt bobino elle
sera en spectacle le 23 avril avec
constance à montigny le bretonneux
voici nicole ferroni dans le kiosque
attention j'étais professeur de svt
pendant quatre ans jusqu'au jour
dramatique et je crois que ça s'est
passé un premier avril a pas un premier
avc passé 22 avril
où j'ai appris par une jolie lettre dans
un quasi les temps mon casier comme mon
poste était supprimé
alors comme moi j'avais déjà été muté en
essonne en revue la guadeloupe
bon moi vous savez c'est un peu galère
et tout
j'avoue que je pense que ça a été le
coup de grâce que cette suppression
passer du coup c'est ce qui m'a poussé à
apprendre un mi temps annualisé pour
pour faire mon spectacle n'ont pas vu ce
monstre en riant elle a beau fourbe
aussi long qu'un procès parce que la
fille quand elle va voir le concevait
larry dans la trop belle calèche avec la
robe dolce gabbana la mini vague dans
les cheveux leur e-mail et tous du coup
le prince trop naïf y voit la fille où
il a envie d'en bas les deux papas peu
moins de cannabis to fly et puis passé
les douze coups de minuit ils ont tangué
une fille qui est trop vilain un caddie
cheveux crépus une robe lidl en train de
conduire le potiron
j'ai commencé à faire du théâtre
d'amateurs depuis sa sphère 12 en
janvier
et c'est vrai que parallèlement à mon
métier de prof je me suis mis à faire du
slam et c'était par contre un vrai
première expérience d'écriture seul et
et de scène tout seul je pense que le la
rencontre entre le théâtre et me stable
fait que sama c'est ce qui m'a poussé
entre guillemets à monter seule sur
scène et à écrire du théâtre pour moi
vous avez venir qui frise la maryse
repli si vous vous en avez besoin d'un
congé férié de lundi mais justement
veulent être chômeuse maryse vous avez
donc tout le loisir maintenant de
rentrer chez vous un vrai chômeuse
rentrez chez vous incommode is the show
must go home ont fait que je me sens
bien à l'humour d'abord
préférentiellement en termes seule
enseigne et c'est un peu lié au fait que
comme comme je suis de nature on va dire
qu'il relate dans la vie je crois que
les gens de toutes façons m'attendais
sur sa faim les gens les amis on va dire
mais de ma famille et que je me suis de
toute façon pas senti de présenter
quelque chose de sérieux parce que
c'était pas je n'aurai pas assumer le
pendant que ça a eu ses carcans je me
suis sentie obligée d'être drôle tout le
temps et en fait c'était pas non plus la
bonne solution parce que j'ai des
passages de mon spectacle qui sont pas
forcément drôle et
et que ça fallait que j'assume aussi
mettez en scène il m'a vachement aidé à
me cadrer en disant un ben non ça c'est
cette partie de textes là tu as écrit un
truc pas drôle tant pis quoi donc je
joue le jeu veut aussi tu as tu joué
sincèrement je veux sincèrement et du
coup c'est vrai que ça m'a dit que mon
spectacle n'était pas mon tueur un
spectacle on rigole tout le temps quand
c'est un spectacle où j'espère courir
parce que c'est quand même le 8 mai mais
c'est pas je pense un truc à la vanne
avec une phrase à rire quand on m'a dit
je dois peut-être pas envie de venir
découvrir la poule est apparue la
première fois que beaucoup n'ont pas
répondu à la question
j'espère que cela ne pense pas que c'est
le port si les hommes étaient capables
d'atteindre soit peu d'initiatives je
crois que ça ce sont les fêtes que je
passerai qui en parle du spectacle a peu
changé le spectacle parce que justement
j'ai vraiment voulu mettre une frontière
ces nouvelles frontières qu'on avait un
mur un mur bien solide entre la scène et
la télé c'est à dire que j'ai pas
cherché à mettre débout mon spectacle à
l'émission de ruquier et j'ai pas
cherché à mettre des sketches que
j'avais écrit pour le pied dans mon
spectacle je dis pas que ben ali
vu tout ce que j'écris est peut-être des
choses que je réussisse et que dans un
deuxième spectacle mais en tout cas
celui là non il n'a pas bougé
la seule chose que ça a fait évoluer
peut-être c'est que je me suis retrouvée
du coup devant un public qui était pas
celui initialement prévu à dire que du
coup j'ai pas mal de gens pas mal je
pense que 80 % des gens qui viennent
nous voir mon spectacle viennent me voir
parce qu'ils m'ont dit à la télé du coup
il ya un certain décalage entre ce que
je présente quand même mon sketch est ce
que je fais en spectacle du coup ça m'a
obligé notamment à resserrer mon
spectacle c'est à dire à couper des
longueurs à pour je vais vous dire pour
lui donner un côté plus télé mais pour
peut-être
éviter des fois le côté trop théâtral
qui pouvait perdre ces gens là n'ont
autour des voeux début des very cool et
oued et je suis désolé là je sais que
très souvent de partisans de l'oeuvre
est déçu dans votre imaginaire tout est
apparue heures et puis ensuite tout le
reste les autres animaux les houches les
crocos nick quinn avait zéro le mot
sapiens ne vit pas seulement ceux du
foulard vous doter les frères le dioxyde
de carbone est ce que la personne savez
j'aime câbles et les écrans tactiles
quatre ans l'émission briguer c'est
vraiment une vitrine vraiment une
vitrine donc c'est une vitrine pour pour
tous c'est à dire c'est une vitrine
auprès du public et c'est vrai que ça
potentiellement ça peut ramener du monde
après par contre c'est éphémère c'est à
dire que on voit que si jamais on
s'arrête de faire de la télé eh bien le
remplissage et les moindres aussi du
coup mais c'est aussi une vitrine auprès
de certains programmateurs ça a vraiment
permis en tout cas à titre personnel moi
que je puisse démissionner l'éducation
nationale je pense que si j'avais pas eu
cette cette émission leur pareil ici
avait dû fonctionner vraiment juste par
le biais de mon spectacle va être
programmée et que c'est sûr que j'aurais
une ascension qui est très très lente et
voilà son été sur l'été autre chose je
pense que j'aurais peut-être pas
démissionner je n'ai pas eu ce courage
là de me dire non cette ville allez fini
maintenant je me lance et la voilà
bonjour moi je me présente je m'appelle
booba chez rappeur sera partagée et
durable puis à 13h traitant comme crosby
voilà moi je suis là pour nicole de
partir je voulais pas le faire parce que
je veux c'est un peu chez les maps est
franchement maintenant trois noms mais
durable comme ça dans le théâtre c'est
lui qui tracasse a fait dire combien
delà de la multiculture emparé du
spectacle donc je fais des chroniques
sur france inter donc je passe dans
l'émission on va tous y passer de
frédéric lopez hanter les normands
j'avais
une série qui s'appelle vdm qui était
censé sortir sur un t1 mais je sais pas
je crois qu'avec des sombres histoires
de production de problèmes ce qui fait
que ça sortira je ne sais pas quand
après je suis à l'affiché d'un long
métrage qui s'appelle n'importe qui
c'est le film de rémi dallaire le
montpelliérain là qui fait plein de vue
sur internet qu'elle est censée sortir
en printemps et comme on peut le
constater
non mais là on est en avril et enfin
bientôt et et en fait on n'a pas fini de
tourner certaines scènes y ce qui me
laisse penser qu'il ne sortira pas au
printemps comme prévu mais je pense cet
été avec celui-là de spectacle je joue
encore jusqu'en avril 2014 vous ai
jamais vu ou en interview vous êtes
journaliste depuis pas longtemps non
donc moi je vais présenter sur olga fond
de flacons stein je ne sais pas pourquoi
je me présente parce que et ben j'ai
participé à ce spectacle 9 la boule ou
nicole parce que c'est petit jeune qui
commence et je pense pour un peu en
route the road sa carrière ça me fait
plaisir de faire des featuring qu'on me
dise dans les milieux voilà seize
matches note seront là
l'africom de montigny le bretonneux et
avec un bep de 23 avril à bientôt le
casque est maintenant un nouveau sujet
de la rédaction venu tout droit de
jérusalem un trésor quasiment inédit
s'expose à versailles en partenariat
avec le conseil général des hauts de
seine le château accueille jusqu'au 14
juillet l'exposition trésors du saint
sépulcre un trésor constitué de présents
offerts par des fidèles et des pèlerins
parmi lesquels les rois d'europe et
notamment de france les rois de france
on était toujours des protecteurs des
lieux saints et ont donc contribué par
des présences onctueux à la célébration
du culte du vin à jérusalem l'exposition
présente au visiteur un extraordinaire
ensemble d'oeuvres d'art accumulées au
cours de l'histoire des pièces
d'orfèvrerie ou des vêtements
liturgiques d'exception sont à découvrir
parmi plus de 250 chef-d'oeuvre inconnu
et restaurer à cette occasion parce que
ce trésor sans être véritablement cacher
parce qu'il n'y avait pas volonté de
cacher n'était pas visible puisqu'il
était dans les sacristies du couvent de
saint sauveur à jérusalem à au saint
sépulcre à bethléem un peu aussi à
nazareth à une carène donc dispersé et
là ça a été donc l'occasion de les
étudier bien sûr de les restaurer aussi
que tous ces objets ont servi servent
encore donc voir les objets c'est
extraordinaire mais c'est aussi les
romaines dans le contexte et c'est à
dire expliqué la fonction ni pièces
l'exposition se prolonge à la maison de
chateaubriand neuf peintures y sont
présentés complétant ainsi le projet
tant artistiques qu'historique
et encore quelques dates à noter avant
d'aller aux bébés nageurs le 27 avril
jean michel ribes présentera son théâtre
sans animaux nouvelle version au prisme
à elancourt et du 24 au 27 avril vous
pourrez encore voir philippe torreton
danse tyranneaux de bergerac au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le 17 mai la parabole de pascal antonini
sera présenté à la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt débattre que vous pouvez
retrouver sur internet aux adresses qui
s'affiche et n'oubliez pas que chaque
semaine sur le www.kia.ca qui point fr
vous pouvez gagner des places de
spectacle moi je serais vous je
profiterai et je vous dis à bientôt
à bientôt le cabba